well there have been two explosions
outside kabul airport the taliban is
saying now at least 13 people have been
killed many more injured but medical
sources are saying the number of dead
could actually be as high as 25. this
all comes after the united states
australia and the uk warned people to
stay away because of what they were
calling an imminent threat from an isil
offshoot in the country
thousands though had been gathering
outside the airport for days now in
hopes of fleeing the country after the
taliban took over
well the taliban has since condemned the
blasts their spokesman has tweeted and i
quote the islamic emirate strongly
condemns the bombing targeting civilians
at kabul airport the explosion took
place in an area where u.s forces are
responsible for security
well we have multiple correspondents
covering this for us charlie angela is
there for us in london across european
reaction as well alan fisher is
monitoring reactions from the pentagon
in the u.s kimberley halcott is outside
the white house but first let's speak to
rob mcbride he's on the ground there for
us in kabul rob as we've been saying
this mounting death toll and we know
dozens injured in hospital a very
fast-moving story can you talk us
through what we know right now
that's right this was an extremely
deadly attack it happened late thursday
afternoon local time here in afghanistan
it was at the so-called abbey gate this
is one of the gates at kabul
international airport it's one of the
gates where we've seen these scenes of
chaos uh over the day
days this week and uh also last week it
we it was one of the gates that was
being used by people who are
eligible for evacuation flights who've
been going in to get onto flights but
also we've seen people there thronging
the gates people trying to get on some
of them maybe legitimately have reason
to be on those flights and have been
cleared to be on those flights but lots
of other people who are just desperate
to get on any flights they can to get
out of afghanistan we know that there
was one explosion first of all but this
was called a what they know it's called
a complex attack it was planned to be in
different stages and it was shortly
followed by a second explosion a
colleague from french television who was
close by has re reported
seeing a surge of people coming away
from the point of this explosion a lot
of them at the front of this crowd of
people carrying injured injured people
people injured in the blast among them
sadly a number of uh children also
amongst all of this crowd surging away
from the scene a lot of taliban taliban
firing in the air trying to disperse
the crowds there are some reports of
maybe in the confusion and maybe
exchanges of gunfire with some of the
militaries of the different countries
around uh the perimeter of the f of the
airport but that has not been confirmed
uh but certainly scenes that we have
been uploaded onto social media and that
we're now seeing uh here in our in our
office really show utter devastation at
the scene of this explosion as you could
imagine it was in a very crowded area
and an awful lot of bodies of men women
and children and we know from scenes
that have been reaching us from a number
of clinics and hospitals they have
really been inundated with
injured being taken to all of these
places so the casualty figures are still
not known at this stage but we are
talking uh in terms of scores of
casualties in terms of people injured
and also dead and it came at the end of
a very tense day for the last 24-36
hours we have been hearing repeated
warnings about an imminent attack from
islamic states some sort of bombing at
the airport which is a very vulnerable
target as we know in fact we were
talking uh to uh one security source
what a an operative who's been here in
in kabul for a number of years now and
he says he had never seen a warning like
this being confirmed by so many sources
so many countries so many intelligence
agencies and militaries of so many
countries including the taliban the
taliban have been warning about this
attack as well and also warning that its
soldiers now its taliban fighters were
also
going to be in the front line should
there be an attack like this which there
has been this thursday evening well the
taliban i believe rob are now saying
that the presence of foreign forces
there are to blame for the attack you
mentioned that they were fairly frantic
in the aftermath of those blasts there
was plenty of chaos what is the
situation like on the streets now there
is the taliban on top of things in terms
of security
i mean the the taliban
as everybody else is looking at the
airport as really the the major focus
now the the for security concerns that's
where all the chaos is that's where
sadly we have seen people trampled in
stampedes we've seen all of these scenes
of chaos it has been around the airport
and the taliban have blamed uh squarely
and in their their view fairly the
americans for this be for their
continued presence they don't want to
see them extend their operation past
august the 31st they blame the us for
not allowing some of these crowds of
people into the airport itself they say
it would take the pressure off this
perimeter the pressure which they have
had to bear and in recent days they have
had to try to bolster with their the
introduction of special forces trying to
push people back from the perimeter so
they uh it
could be argued they would blame the
americans wouldn't they but they they
certainly said the americans are to
blame and have contributed to a lot of
the chaos that we're seeing there at the
airport elsewhere in the capital it's a
different scene the taliban does seem to
be in charge you see their presence they
have a very high profile they are at
checkpoints around the streets for the
past week or more we have seen a gradual
increase
in taliban
they have been
manning roadblocks they have been
outside the front of ministries or
potential other targets such as hotels
where there are foreigners keeping
largely control there has been some
tension on the streets there has been an
easy calm but by and large the taliban
very much you do get the sense that they
are cementing their control their hold
uh on kabul and the hope is that
gradually people will get used to them
being on the streets that people are
uneasy about having the taliban here
after uh 20 years and having their
return but the taliban's hope is that
gradually people will become accustomed
will become easier at least of having
their presence here in kabul rob mcbride
they're on the streets of kabul for us
with all the latest thank you so much
rob
well let's now cross over to washington
dc and speak to alan fisher he's across
all the reaction from there alan i
believe we are now hearing from
officials that a number of american
troops are among the dead what else are
you hearing from the pentagon
the u.s ambassador in kabul has
confirmed just in the last few minutes
that four american marines have been
killed and three others have been
injured in the bombing at kabul airport
interestingly enough 24 hours ago the
troops that were guarding the gates and
processing people through for flights to
leave
from afghanistan were given advice on
what to look for if there was a
suspected suicide bomber that is because
there was a high security alert they had
credible evidence that there was going
to be an attack and so the troops were
warned this is what you need to look for
this is what you need to keep an eye on
and still even after that warning they
were processing people through those
gates risking their own lives to make
sure that these people could get out of
the country uh the bomb blast came at
abby gate it was a complex attack
according to the pentagon not just
because there was one bomb blast at abby
gate as people moved away from the area
towards barnes hotel where many
foreigners had been staged including
americans and americans had been led
away from there just shortly before the
bombing that is where the second bomb
went off killing a number of people
there as well so just to to reiterate
what we've been told just in the last
few minutes the u.s ambassador in kabul
confirming that there are four u.s
marines dead and three have been injured
alan no claim of responsibility yet but
obviously as rob was saying plenty of
warnings plenty of threats around an
attack like this what are you hearing
from security sources there around who
they think was behind this i know
there's been lots of talk
well if you look at the timeline on
tuesday joe biden he spoke to the
american people he said look there is a
threat from isil k which is the offshoot
of isil which operates in afghanistan
has been responsible for a number of
attacks particularly this year he said
that there was a threat the taliban were
aware of it but more importantly the
americans were aware of it you flash
forward 24 hours and the us embassy in
kabul is warning people that there is a
threat a credible threat of a possible
attack and so americans and others
should stay away from the gates at the
airport and also away from the airport
environs itself and then
less than 24 hours after that in fact
about 12 hours later you have this
attack so people are drawing the direct
line from a through to c and saying they
believe that isil k was certainly
responsible for this this if true
then causes a huge problem for joe biden
although he has said every time he's
asked no he doesn't trust the taliban
one of the things that has been
negotiated
in qatar and in other places is that the
taliban say
no groups will be allowed to use
afghanistan as a base for operations if
the taliban cannot stop isil k from
launching an operation like this right
in the heart of kabul there will be
questions about just how big their writ
lies in afghanistan itself to try and
stop other groups launching not attacks
not just in afghanistan itself but
perhaps even targeting the united states
which of course takes us back to 20
years ago and what happened with al
qaeda operating out of afghanistan and
the attacks that we saw in the united
states so this poses a real question for
joe biden on security and not one he's
going to be able easily able to walk
away from he has been briefed there are
contingency plans
if they want to extend the august 31st
deadline lloyd austin who is the defense
secretary was with the president in the
situation room for a few hours this
morning he's now back at the pentagon
and clearly there will be some hard
thinking to do
across the potomac
at the pentagon and in the white house
itself well let's cross the potomac now
um alan fisher there with all the latest
for us from the pentagon we'll have all
the live briefing for you here later on
um when that happens but let's speak in
the meantime to our white house
correspondent kimberly halcott kimberley
as alan was mentioning there president
biden's spending quite a few hours today
in the situation room and his schedule
really up ended today as well
yeah that's right the u.s president was
scheduled to meet with the israeli prime
minister naftali bennett that has been
delayed we don't know if that meeting
now will happen today or whether it has
been pushed off to tomorrow it is still
unclear in fact we don't have a sense of
the president's precise schedule and
that is because he's continuing to be
briefed
regularly by his team of advisors
earlier in the day he was in the
situation room we can confirm where he
met with his secretary of state his
defense secretary lloyd austin also the
vice president of the united states
returning to the u.s from her tour in
asia kamala harris aboard air force two
was also participating in those
briefings virtually
this is so that they could assess the
intelligence that has been coming in
since these two reported blasts and of
course uh there are concerns that there
could be more and as a result the united
states
interacting with the commanders on the
ground in kabul and around afghanistan
in order to
try and coordinate next steps now
officially the u.s president and the
white house still sticking with that
august 31st withdrawal date for the u.s
troops to
leave afghanistan but the u.s president
when he announced that date said it was
contingent on the taliban ensuring that
the evacuations could continue and that
there would continue to be safe passage
to and from the kabul airport well
obviously that has not been the case now
we have not had full claims of
responsibility for these attacks but
already i can tell you that members of
congress are blaming the taliban
including one member of the president's
own democratic party bob menendez a
prominent senator and chair of the
foreign relations committee saying that
he condemns these attacks and also says
as we wait for more details one thing is
clear we can't trust the taliban with
american security this is a full-fledged
humanitarian crisis and not surprisingly
the president's republican critics on
capitol hill also seizing on this
to criticize the u.s president
saying he has blood on his hands and
also from one veteran now a
representative in congress in the house
of representatives dan crenshaw saying
we are still at war
accusing the president of not ending the
war but just giving the enemy the new
advantage to the new advantage or a new
advantage and he is encouraging the
president to go on the offense
senator lindsey graham in the u.s senate
taking it a step further saying on
social media that i urge the biden
administration to re-establish our
presence at bagram as an alternative to
the
kabul airport now of course we should
remember that bagram is where the u.s
forces were posted uh until they
abruptly left uh and that is now no
longer a location for the u.s military
repositioning instead for those
evacuation flights at kabul airport so
whether or not that is something the
white house is considering we have no
confirmation of that our opportunity to
hear from the u.s president have for the
moment has been dashed with the delay of
that meeting with the israeli prime
minister that bilateral meeting was one
opportunity where the u.s president
could appear and also the press
secretary's briefing has also been
delayed so we are still very much in
have the open questions unanswered as to
not only what the next steps are or
but also whether the august 31st
deadline is still going ahead we can
tell you the u.s president said when he
announced that august 31st deadline that
the reason he was sticking to it despite
international pressure despite
congressional pressure is that he said
that every day that american troops
remain in theater in country it was
another day of risk but now as alan
fisher has reported we have seen there
are american casualties american troop
casualties and uh deaths and injuries
and so uh this is certainly going to put
the pressure on joe biden even more to
perhaps examine the contingency plans
that he had the pentagon draw up
in terms of what happens next
kimberly you mentioned all the pressure
and the criticism on joe biden not only
from congress but and and actually also
the republicans but also he's been
facing a lot of criticism from his own
party now that we have seen these
casualties within the u.s troops who are
in kabul does that change the calculus
now the political calculus going forward
for
biden well what it does is it makes the
president much more politically
vulnerable uh there were two members of
congress one democrat one republican
that went to afghanistan against the
wishes of nancy pelosi the house speaker
in order to conduct oversight on this
evacuation process because they were so
concerned and in fact one democratic
member and it's important to point out
these aren't just members of congress
these are u.s veterans that traveled
over there against the wishes of their
colleagues
that they said that american lives would
be lost if the president continued with
this august 31st deadline now that has
occurred and that is going to be very
difficult for the president to uh
respond to as this is a white house that
has been struggling to find its footing
with respect to afghanistan they have
cast blame on the previous trump
administration for striking this deal
that they say predicated the withdrawal
but the bottom line is the u.s president
is the commander in chief of the u.s
military and he is currently sitting in
the oval office not his predecessor so
these real-time decisions that are being
made now in consultation with the chair
of the joint chiefs of staff and members
of his cabinet and intelligence
officials those squarely fall on joe
biden's shoulders and we can tell you
that here in the united states his
approval rating has been falling as a
result of how this is playing out the
optics of so many people desperate at
the airport not just american citizens
but also
afghans afghans who supported the u.s
mission for a generation now desperately
trying to flee and this is not playing
well on american television screens and
on their personal smartphone devices
where they may be getting their news
we've seen the poll numbers the
president who came into office so
popular after a very controversial
donald trump now seeing his approval
ratings according to some of the latest
polls falling into the low 40 percent
and the disapproval rating
for the first time i believe above 50 so
this is concerning for this president
but i suspect it is not the political
ramifications that this president is
dealing with right now he is
very well versed and adept when it comes
to foreign policy and this really is a
test of his presidency now and of those
skills acquired as a u.s senator as he
now acts as commander-in-chief to decide
on the next steps for the u.s military
in light of these twin explosions that
have occurred around the kabul airport
kimberly halcott there with all the
latest for us from the white house
thanks so much kimberly
well speaking after those attacks french
president emmanuel macron has promised
to continue working with the u.s to
evacuate those trying to flee
afghanistan
it is obvious that the tension is
increasing greatly we have all known the
risk since the beginning considering the
confusion in kabul and the tension that
has been there since the beginning at
the military airport the next hours will
remain extremely dangerous in kabul and
at the airport
the security situation is not under
control so we will keep with our allies
in particular our american allies in a
discussion which has been developing
about the airport we will do everything
we can to evacuate french nationals and
some afghans
well meanwhile though several countries
have already wrapped up their
evacuations partly because of the
security concerns germany hungary the
netherlands belgium and poland are all
stopping their flights let's speak to
charlie angela she's in london charlie
despite other countries stopping their
flights it does seem the uk even after
these blasters saying that they will
continue with their evacuations
yes boris johnson has just emerged from
his emergency cobra meeting with
some good news for the people who are
still on the ground his conclusion is
that the uk will be able to continue
with its program and timetable for
evacuation remember they had 11 flights
planned to travel out of kabul airport
on thursday he said that the
overwhelming majority of those eligible
have already been evacuated and we're
working on getting the rest of them
through as quickly as possible
but he said we also expect those who
want to leave afghanistan after phase
one that's being before august 31st will
be allowed to do so by
the taliban and they'll be putting
pressure on them but good news for the 1
000 afghan interpreters who have been
eligible for relocation who have still
not left the country um
but
just back to those two attacks because
the locations were very significant for
the british abbey gate was controlled by
british troops and the baron hotel was
really a muster point for all british
passport holders so outside that hotel
would have been some of these afghan
interpreters also any people who are
holding british passports hoping to get
their visas
processed
for travel to the uk inside the hotel
british personnel who've been processing
those visa applications but there's been
no uk personnel injured in those attacks
which would be um good news for some but
some of those people who were injured
might have been hoping to be relocated
to the uk
now we heard that from president
emmanuel macron france is planning on
ending its flights on friday
but the president did say that there are
still several hundred afghans that he
wants to help leave the country 20 buses
with a mixture of french and afghan
citizens on board are sitting outside
the gates of kabul airport at the moment
and the french are in discussions with
the taliban to allow them safe passage
but they have admitted that they might
not be able to evacuate them safely and
there are very few countries left with
any flights as you said that list of
countries who've already stopped their
evacuation flights we can now add norway
to that list they've just wrapped up
their last flight saying it's impossible
to get anyone through the gates so
there's no point and their last flight
has left however nato's secretary
general jen soltenberg has said that the
priority remains to evacuate as many
people as possible it's just not clear
how that's going to happen
but one last point is that since those
attacks we do know there has been a
little bit of aircraft movement
two
c-17as which are strategic airlift um
capability aircraft these are huge nato
uh aircraft have taken off so it seems
that some people or equipment are still
leaving the base
charlie angela there with all the latest
for us from europe and from london thank
you charlie well meanwhile german
chancellor angela merkel has described
these attacks as horrendous
we don't know all the details but the
terrorists were targeting people waiting
outside the airport gates hoping to
leave they want security and freedom for
themselves and therefore this is an
absolutely horrendous attack in a very
very tense situation and my thoughts are
with the victims and their families
and former afghan chief executive abdul
abdullah has also issued a statement
saying i strongly condemn the terrorist
attack at kabul airport which killed and
wounded a large number of civilians my
thoughts and prayers are with the
victims and their families at this
difficult time
and we've now also had reaction to
what's happened in kabul from stefan
dujaric now he's the spokesperson for
the u.n secretary general antonio
guterres
he condemns this terrorist attack which
killed and injured a number of civilians
and extends his deep condolences to the
families of those killed he stands in
solidarity and wishes a speedy recovery
to those injured this incident
underscores the volatility of the
situation on the ground in afghanistan
but also strengthens our resolve as we
continue to deliver urgent assistance
across the country in support of the
afghan people
well let's now bring in david des roches
he's a professor at the national defense
university here in qatar and there's
also a former pentagon director of
arabian peninsula affairs he joins us
now from doha professor thank you for
your time again this hour as we've been
saying you served in afghanistan and i
really would like you to give us a sense
on the ground of how this might have
looked like as it was carried out in
this area near the airport
well i i i can only give you my
supposition and i've only seen
photographs and videos probably the same
that you've seen but normally with a
complex attack like this what you do is
you set off an explosion that's designed
to breach defenses and induce a sense of
panic uh you know you have all these
people crammed in trying to get through
the gate so the explosion sets off a
sense of panic kills some of the guards
and then when the people are panicking
you fire at them as you move so it's an
extremely immoral and murderous act it's
uh calculated with a level of
viciousness that uh uh you know it's
almost hard to comprehend but this was
what um we saw at the bataclan attacks
in paris and the foil attack against the
stad de france and
it's not entirely dissimilar to what we
saw at the ariana grande uh
concert in manchester um
professor we heard from our
correspondent in london charlie there
that these were two areas that were very
strategically important for the british
now these were also close to the airport
but not within the airport complex
themselves can you describe that area
for us and just how heavily fortified or
not indeed it may be
well i haven't seen i haven't seen the
area in in a considerable amount of time
but um you know the barren hotel was
considered to be the most secure hotel
in afghanistan and it was located within
what was once the isaf perimeter so
these are areas that were probably under
a degree of control either directly by
nato forces or by contractor subordinate
to nato forces so you're in sort of a
gray area where you had uh taliban
controlling entrance and egress and
probably moving among some of the roads
there's a road that has a wall on it
that leads up to the abbey gate that was
probably thronged with people the
airport's on one side and the barren
hotel is on the other side of the road
so it's it's in an area that is of uh
you know mixed responsibility but given
that the british were conducting um
evacuation operations they're probably
directly under control of them
although with a perimeter that was under
the control of the taliban
how do you try to fortify an area or
provide security in an area like that
when you have so many civilians trying
to get on planes is that even possible
i don't think it is i mean really the
only way you can secure an area
ultimately is by having separation
between it and everything else and so
when you have a large number of people
coming in you know what we've seen in
years of of uh you know terrorist
attacks by al-qaeda by daesh by um
all these other groups is that at some
point when you have large numbers of
people you have to erect a fence and
large numbers of people congregate
waiting to get through that fence so
that large number of people becomes
itself a target for a terrorist group
and quite frankly um you can keep
pushing out the perimeter that requires
more and more soldiers that will allow
you to provide a level of security for
your soldiers but it increases the level
of vulnerability for in this instance
the afghans who are trying to get in and
what we've seen is whoever carried out
this attack doesn't particularly care
who they kill as long as they kill a lot
of them and we now know that also
included a number of u.s troops and i
see that the taliban is trying to lay
the blame on the us saying that this was
actually an area that they were in
control of i'm curious given that
we're hearing those kinds of lines from
the taliban and it's obviously a very
busy day at the pentagon what is now at
the top of the to-do list in washington
is it about trying to work out exactly
what happened or to try to respond to
really what's happened there in terms of
the politics of it and trying to secure
the area that way
i i think it's
a little bit of both the main task is to
determine what the actual security
situation is on the ground so you know
the question is okay
are there other areas that you know
civilians are mass that suicide bombers
might be amongst them where are areas
that can be infiltrated and attacked and
then what can we do to mitigate them and
if the mitigation measures are effective
then
the mission will continue if the
mitigation measures are ineffective then
there will be some people who will argue
for an immediate withdrawal they'll say
this is just an undefensible position so
attribution will come later
right now the question is in the
aftermath of these attacks what is the
actual situation on the ground what
level of risk are we exposing
our forces and the evacuee population to
and then
what do we have a plan that can mitigate
that level of risk is there an
acceptable level of risk or do we have
to go with a more drastic plan involving
either
active military operations or a
withdrawal in terms of trying to
mitigate risk there's obviously been a
lot of speculation that the group behind
this attack could be isil k and
obviously there hasn't yet been any
claim of responsibility but if it is
indeed isil k given that there were a
number of warnings about the threat that
they posed what does that mean in terms
of trying to allay risk going forward is
there is that even possible
well let me let me give you a caveat on
warnings so
the problem is never that there weren't
that there wasn't a warning the problem
is that there are too many warnings and
about you know there's usually a hundred
warnings every day and maybe one of
those will be you know a legitimate
threat so you can always after the fact
go back and say well this was a warning
and obviously this happened it wasn't
listened to but generally i mean i would
be shocked if there weren't multiple
warnings of other things that just
turned out not to be true so
so um
you know that's an analytical problem
that we see over and over and over again
so the question is you know with isis k
it's a group that we know is in open
warfare with the taliban is looking to
discredit the taliban is in open warfare
with the west is looking to kill as many
people in the west as they can
the big question is going to be is the
taliban
not in control of areas around it is the
taliban somehow facilitating this
because a rapid withdrawal of western
forces you know
enhances the taliban's role the fact
that
educated afghans are leaving kabul uh
that discredits the taliban's claim to
be a legitimate governing entity so
there may be a degree of collaboration
there
given the fact that the taliban is a
loosely run organization it's quite
possible there's a faction within there
that you know
may have carried this out itself or
turned a blind eye or you know was
opposed so there's a whole range of
options we don't know what we do know is
that you have an insecure situation
that's become a lot more insecure and
that something has to be taken seriously
and quite frankly if you wait for
perfect intelligence you're going to be
at risk because you'll never get perfect
intelligence
david des roches there professor at the
national defense university in qatar and
a former pentagon director of arabian
peninsula affairs thanks again for
joining us sir here on al jazeera great
to get your expertise
well if you are just joining us here on
al jazeera there have been two
explosions outside kabul airport the
taliban is saying at least 13 people
have been killed many more injured but
medical sources are actually saying that
number of dead could be as high as 25.
the u.s has said that four marines have
been killed and three others injured and
all of this comes after the u.s
australia and the uk all warned people
to stay away from that airport area
because of what they were calling an
imminent threat from an isil offshoot in
the country thousands though have been
gathering outside the airport for days
in hopes of fleeing the country after
the taliban took over
well witnesses to the attacks today have
been describing what they saw when those
explosions went off
it was time for the evening prayer when
an explosion happened i saw about 70
vehicles carried around 150 injured to
the hospital
people were standing at the airport gate
for evacuation when the blast happened
my cousin was also wounded on his leg so
he brought him to the hospital
well our correspondent charlotte bellas
is in kabul and she headed for the
airport very soon after the attack and
she describes what she saw
we initially heard the first explosion
around 5 40 p.m
we headed towards the scene and
there was chaos as you can imagine there
was a lot of gunfire as the taliban
tried to push people away and control
the scene
we tried to move closer towards abby
gate we heard another explosion uh there
was more heavy gunfire there was
hundreds of people running towards us
and there was heavy smoke in the air we
heard sirens coming from the airport and
the taliban fighters that guard that
that south gate where we had arrived
were pushing everyone back quite
frantically they were panicked
themselves uh a few ambulances drove
past us and and we've stayed there for
about half an hour and heavy gunfire
continued throughout we've tried to talk
to uh us military forces over this time
but they they are keeping quite uh quiet
about their operations uh but we do know
that three u.s soldiers were injured and
i was just down there earlier this week
at this exact location at abbey gate and
the taliban don't let you film around
the airport's perimeter so i use my
phone to film and capture some of what
was happening there were hundreds of
people around abby gates this was just a
couple of days ago there were taliban
checkpoints around there and then
there's a there's a post with three
americans in it at that time they were
overlooking the scene at the top of
about a three meter high concrete wall
surrounded by barbed wire and they were
overlooking the hundreds of people
trying to get through people below them
were waving pieces of paper saying no i
i deserve to get on some of these
flights here's my certificate from
working with the americans and what have
you and and they had the gate closed at
that time just overlooking the scene we
heard of an isil threat
earlier this week it didn't seem to
deter anybody but then it was only
coming from the us and it was quite
vague
over the last 24 hours or so
there were more threats issued by
various countries talking about this
this isil threat i contacted the taliban
this morning to ask if they knew any
more details about uh have any more
intelligence on it they said uh from
what we understand isil is planning some
type of car bombing in and around the
airport and that they're looking for
maximum damage
after we received that we decided to
stay clear of the airport today as did
other media networks uh who we had been
going down there all of us every day but
today most people stayed clear because
there was the threats level and then the
amount of information we were getting
was getting more credible and coming
from more sources
and uh it was more kind of watch and
wait i i do have to say that my producer
ducked down there briefly just to have a
quick look from a distance and you see
there were far fewer people down there
today that the taliban were incredibly
tense and that's saying something
because they've been tense or weak uh
but very much pushing people back trying
to keep them at a distance from the
airport uh and were quite agitated when
he got down there and they told him to
leave immediately so everyone was on
alert today but at abigail it appears
that there had been crowds forming and
that they hadn't managed to disperse
them when this explosion occurred